こんにちは なかつまじょうたチャンネル解説委員です 今回はですね
令和7年8月21日の板橋区議会文教児童委員会の解説をします
報告事項とか委員の質疑応答とか色々あります これらを深く掘り下げていこうと思います
資料が多いだけに情報もほんと豊富で、今回の私たちのミッションはこれらの文書から
板橋区がどんな課題に直面しててどう動こうとしているのか その核心を探って重要ポイントを明らかにすることです
では早速ですが、まずは子どもたちの支援の現場がらめていきましょうか まず注目したいのは子ども家庭総合支援センターの活動報告ですね
令和6年度の相談件数、これ年間で3,700件を超えてるんですね 多いですね
その中でも特に虐待に関する相談が増えているようで 援助課が受けた相談のうち半数以上700件近くが心理的虐待に関するものだということです
ええ、この心理的虐待の相談件数が突出して多いというのは 見過ごせない点ですよね
まあもちろん相談が増えた背景には問題への認識が広まったとか あるいは相談しやすくなったっていう側面もあるのかもしれませんが
はい ただそれでもこれだけ多くの声が上がっているということはですね
家庭内で見えにくいストレスとか困難が確実に増えている可能性を視察しているんじゃないかと
言葉の暴力とか無視とか子どもの前での夫婦喧嘩なんかも含まれますから 範囲は広いですし
これが今の子どもたちを取り巻くひとつの現実なんでしょうね 深刻ですね
それに連動するように子どもたちを一時的に保護する件数も増えている 令和6年度は311件で
前の年から1.2倍です 区の施設だけでは足りなくて里親さんとか乳児院とか
外部にお願いするケースも結構あるんですね96件 そういう状況もあるみたいで
なんか現場はかなり逼迫している感じですかね そうなんです
一方で長期的に家庭での養育が難しい子どもたち 社会的養護が必要な子という言い方をしますが
この子たちを里親さんに託すっていう動きはまだこう十分に進んでいないという現状がありますね
そうなんですね 対象の子どもさんが約200人いる中で 里親委託は24件
登録している里親家庭は50以上あるのにです やはりマッチングの難しさとか
里親さんの成り手不足それからサポート体制 こういう寝深い課題があるようです
区もですね 里親制度を知ってもらうための活動 アウトリーチって言いますけどそれとか
一時保護の受入れを通じて経験を積んでもらうとか まあ工夫はしているようですが
どうすれば子どもたちにとって 最善の環境である家庭的な養護をもっと広げられるのか
これは本当に大きな問いだと思います 地域全体での見守りという点ではどうでしょう
要保護児童対策地域協議会 通称要対協ですか これの活動報告もありますね
はい 学校とか保育園とか約400か所を回って気になる子の情報を共有したり 支援の方針を確認したりしていると
早期発見のためにチェックリストを使うとか具体的な助言をするみたいな 地味な活動がやっぱり重要なんですね
まさに それに加えてNPOとか そういう民間団体との連携も模索されていますね 例えば、たからっこお届け便
これは食料なんかを必要としている家庭に届ける事業で民生委員さんとか子ども食堂とかが協力している 昨年度は85世代160人以上の子どもたちが利用したそうです
あ、訂正後の数字ですねこれ こうした地域の様々な主体が関わることでより決め細やかな支援が可能になると
ただ議事録からは 支援を届けやすくすることと相談に来る親子のプライバシーを守ること このバランスの難しさっていう声も聞こえてきますね
なるほど それは難しいですね 難しい家事取りが求められています 新しい取り組みとしては子ども家庭センター機能の強化
つまり妊娠期から切れ目なく相談に乗れる体制作り それからあとは産後ドゥーラの活用支援も始まっているんですね
これ3個のお母さんを専門的に支える人のことですよね そうですそうです
でもこれも何か利用したくても予約が取りにくいとか 特に急ぎの場合とか人気の時間帯は難しいなんていう課題も出ているみたいですね
ええ 利用料の負担軽減とかあとはもっと多くの人にこういう支援があるんだよって知ってもらう その必要性が議論されていますね
面白いなと思ったのは家が片付いていないから人に来てもらうのはちょっとっていう そういう心理的なハードルもあるっていう指摘があったことですね
ああわかりますねそれ これはもしかしたら支援を受けること自体がまだちょっと特別なことっていう意識があるのかもしれない
子育てのしんどさをもっと気軽に助けてって言えるような そういう空気づくりも実は大事なのかもしれないですね
なるほど いやー子育てを取り巻く課題って本当に多様なんだなっていうのがよくわかりますね さてちょっと視点を変えて次は教育の分野を見ていきましょうか
はい 教育委員会の動き これもいろいろありますが特に大きな変化と言えそうなのが 中学の部活動の地域移行
それと春休みの日程変更資料 このあたりでしょうか そうですね
まず部活動の地域以降ですが これは教員の働き方改革っていう側面と
あとは少子化が進む中で子どもたちのスポーツとか文化活動の機会を どう持続的に確保していくかっていう 2つの大きな目的がありますね
2028年度までの3年間で段階的に進める計画 板橋区立中学校部活動地域移行実施計画2028 これをこれから策定するという方針です
国の動きとも連動していますね ただ議事録を読むとですね 単に先生の負担を減らすってそれだけじゃないだろうと
移行する先の地域の指導者の方にどうやってその教育的な目的意識これを共有してもらうのか
生徒の成長って具体的に何を指すのかみたいな 結構根本的な問いかけもありましたね 最近ほら 高校野球でも指導者のあり方が問われるケースがありましたけど
単に技術を教えるだけじゃない その人間的な成長の部分をどう担保するのかっていうのは確かに重要ですよね
まさにそこが核心ですね 区の説明ではあくまで生徒の成長機会の確保が第一であって
そのために教員の負担を減らして結果的に教育の質問を上げるっていう 両輪で考えているという説明のようです なるほど
指導者の質についてはスポーツマンシップとかハラスメント防止の意識とかそういうのを採用時に確認するとはしていますが
学校という枠組みが外れた時にその理念をどう浸透させていくのかっていうのはこれから具体的に詰めていく必要がありそうです
まあ大局的に見ればこれまで学校が担ってきた青年育成の役割の一部が 地域社会へと移っていくっていう大きな転換点と言えるでしょうね
保護者とか生徒からするともっと切実な問題もありますよね うちの子が入る部活はいつどう変わるのみたいな 具体的な情報が早く欲しいという声
それはそうでしょうね これは中学校選びにも影響しますからね 実際に野球部で先行して始まった地域クラブ課では開始時期がちょっと急だったんじゃないか
っていう意見もあったみたいです この秋以降にアンケート調査をして関係者の声を聞く予定だそうですけど
もう一つの大きな変更点が春休みの延長ですね これは令和8年度から今より2日間長くなって4月7日までになる
目的はですね 先生たちが新年度の準備をする時間を暦に関係なくしっかり5日間確保するためだそうです なるほど
先生たちの準備時間を確保するためなんですね これによって入学式とか始業式の日程も変わるんですね
小中学校は2日後ろだおしそうなんです 授業時間が減るんじゃないかっていう心配もありそうですけど その影響は小さいと見込んでいるようです
これも働き方改革の一環と言えそうですね 次は子どもたちが日々過ごす学校の建物
その環境と安全についてみていきましょう 資料を見ると区内の学校施設の改築とか改修が計画的に進められているのがわかりますね
はい 上板橋第一中学校とか志村小学校・志村四中なんかが今進んでいるか、これから着行予定と これから計画される学校、向原小学校
板橋第一中、板橋第五中なんかは単に建て替えるだけじゃなくて地域の他の施設
例えば駅周辺の活性化とか、文化会館とかと連携していくことも考えているみたいですね これは興味深い視点ですね
単なる老朽化対策にとどまらないで学校を核にした地域づくりみたいな発想が見えますよね 特に板橋第一中第五中と文化会館グリーンホールとの連携なんかは
学校と地域のリソースをどうつなげていくかという 未来への投資とも言えそうです 一方で具体的な事例として板橋第六小学校の増改築
これも資料にありますが これを見るとその難しさも浮かび上がってきますね 板橋第六小
近くに大規模マンションができて教室が足りなくなるという 喫緊の課題に対応するためなんですが
限定的な敷地の中で今の校舎を使いながら段階的に工事を進めて 最終的な完成は令和15年度目標と かなり長期に渡る計画です
10年以上かかるんですね そうなんです 地域の人の利用も考えながら法的な制約もある中で
というのはかなりなんていうかパズルのような作業ですよね そして学校の安全という点で避けては通れないのがいじめの問題です
資料では2件の重大自体についての調査結果が報告されています これは非常に重い内容なので慎重に事実を客観的にお使いしたいと思います
まず事案1についてですね これは小学校1年生から5年生にかけて複数の児童から継続的にいじめを受けたとされるケースです
調査の結果申告された28点のうち24件が法律上のいじめに該当すると認定されました
調査報告書とか質疑応答で特に問題視されているのは 学校側の対応の遅れですね
いじめがあったかもしれないというまずその認知 それをきちんと記録して関係者で共有すること
そして初期段階での適切な対応これらに不備があったと指摘されています
転校をきっかけに調査が始まったという経緯とか調査自体にも約2年かかったという点も事態の複雑さを物語っていますね
具体的な再発防施策も挙げられていますね いじめの定義を正しく理解するとか 記録のフォーマットを統一して確実に共有する
子どもからの話の聞き方を改善する 関係者への情報共有を適切に行う
法令やガイドラインの理解を徹底する などなど多岐に渡りますね
ええ 様々な対策が並んでいますが 質疑応答での議論で重要だと感じたのは
個々の先生の頑張りに頼るんじゃなくて 学校全体としての仕組みで対応できるようにしなきゃ意味がないという指摘ですね
ああ仕組みか そうです 例えば報告とか共有のワークフローをちゃんと確立するとか
あるいはAIみたいな技術も活用して記録の負担を減らしつつ確実に情報を残すとか そういう具体的な仕組み作りとそれが本当に現場で機能するかどうかその実行性の担保が今後の大きな課題でしょうね
あとつけ加えると加害者とされる側から十分に話を聞けなかったケースもあったようで これも対応の難しさを示している点だと思います
もう一つの事案2については 調査は終わったけれども被害を受けたお子さんと保護者の移行で結果は公表しないということですね
ええ プライバシーへの配慮がなされたということです さて最後にですね委員会の質疑応答資料8からちょっと具体的な現場の困り事が見える事例を一つ紹介させてください
東新児童館が週末に一時的に閉まらざるを得なかったという話です はい 原因は排水設備の不具合で下の回の保育園に水漏れしてしまった
ああそれは大変ですね それで週末は運営を委託している業者さんが入っていて保育園の洗濯機とかも使えない状況になってしまって
衛生管理上の問題から閉館せざるを得なかったということらしいんです これは日用的な施設の維持管理っていうまあ地味な作業がいかに大切かということとそれが滞ってしまうと
地域住民が必要とするサービス 特に暑い日の避難場所としての児童館の役割とか そういうのに直接影響が出てしまうということを示す象徴的な事例かもしれませんね
そうですね 議員さんからは土曜日だけでもなんとか開けられなかったのかという意見も出ていましたけど
やはり安全とか衛生を確保しながらサービスを続けることの現実的な難しさがここには現れているように思います
さてここまで児童福祉 教育改革 学校環境と安全 そして現場の具体的な課題まで本当に多岐に渡る資料を見てきました
虐待への対応強化とか里親支援 部活動の地域移行 学校の建て替え いじめへの組織的対応
板橋区がさまざまな課題に継続的に取り組んでいる様子が伺いますよね そうですね
これらの報告全体を通して見えてくるのは 少子高齢化とか働き方の変化 子どもたちの安全 施設の老朽化といった
現代の自治体がどこも共通して抱えるような複雑な課題に対して 板橋区が具体的に向き合って対策を打とうとしている
その姿だと思います ただ同時に理想通りにはいかない現場の難しさというのも感じますね
例えば一時保護所の定員の問題とか里親のマッチングの難しさ 地域移行での価値観の共有
いじめ対応での情報連携の壁 施設の維持管理の現実 そういった実践面での苦労とか課題も資料の行間から透けて見えてくる気がします
心理的虐待のように見えにくい問題の深刻化 それから地域移行を支える指導者の確保 先生たちの負担の問題 学校施設の更新と地域連携の複雑さ
いじめ対応の仕組み化の難しさ なんかこれらの課題ってそれぞれ独立しているようでいて 実は根っこの部分でつながっている
そういう部分もあるのかもしれないですね そう思います そこで最後にあなたに考えてみてほしい問いがあります
これらの報告書が示すさまざまな取組とか計画 それらを踏まえた上でですね さらに一歩進んで 板橋区の子どもたちと家庭を本当に支える環境を築くためには現在の計画以上に
私たち地域社会全体としてどのような協力とか連携の形がありえるんでしょうか 分野横断的な もっと積極的な関わり方はどこにあると考えますか